[Music]
all righty everybody this is the moment
you've all been waiting for because it
is time to play jeopardy warm up we get
to see which of our contestants knows
the most about las vegas this one is so
easy this one is really yeah that's it
for now let's introduce our three
contestants brian loftus here's
christian and also ted now let me say
something right here because this is
almost how easy this is it's like if i
asked you what is the roman themed
resort on the strip that's how easy this
is i know you don't i know it's not that
easy
so here we go you will have 15 seconds
to answer this and look how easy this is
there you go
this performer is also known as mr las
vegas all right okay chris you're right
yeah chris you're right
uh-oh hey by the way if you don't get
this one you're kicked off the show for
a week i just hope christians say uh-oh
oh no
you got five seconds you might want to
change it christian
oh no time's up okay let's go to
let's go to ted
let's go view over on nasa uh
right side of the screen that is wayne
wayne
viva las vegas okay christian
let's go to you i said frank sinatra oh
josephine brian
who is wayne newton
christian will you please read this off
the screen
ryan
brian brennan is not
all right thank you very much for
playing christian you were kicked off
the show for exactly one week
uh ted gets it brian gets it it was mr
wayne newton mr las vegas wayne newton
hey don't forget join us tonight at 11
o'clock we'll have much